all here I'm sharing the stage with
Shashank Joshi who's the defense editor
of The Economist who will be chairing
this session and is indeed an alumni of
rusi as many of you here are actually
which is great to see and our main
speakers for Jeremy Fleming the director
of gchq
we have had a tradition in Russi for
quite a number of years now of having an
annual defense lecture from the current
chief of the defense staff which takes
place every December just before
Christmas and reflects russi's
long-standing relationship with Her
Majesty's his Majesty's armed forces and
it's followed by a grand Christmas party
party with mince pies and Limitless rusi
wine and indeed a choir
I can't guarantee you most of that after
this lecture but I there will be drinks
served in a in a suitably security safe
environment right after this lecture
outside but the fact that we're holding
this lecture is an indication that Russi
is about more than defense today a very
large part of our research is an other
equally important aspects of the
security agenda or financial crime
terrorism organized crime and of course
cyber security and I think it's
especially important uh to have that
public profile that public discussion of
security issues because as I suspect for
Jeremy will tell us shortly
effective National Security in today's
world means a broad public private
partnership across a whole range of
areas you can't tackle so many of the
National Security challenges our country
faces without an active role by various
different parts of the private sector
the voluntary sector and so on
government can't do it alone the
national cyber security center with
which sir Jeremy was involved in
establishing as a important indicator of
that so Shashank will cover in his
remarks The Rules of Engagement for the
lecture and subsequent to q a so I won't
talk about that myself
all I would say by way of conclusion
is that you have no doubt heard quite a
bit about this lecture in the media over
the last 24 hours uh understandably
focused I think on on latest
developments latest horrific development
on the ground in Ukraine
um and absolutely right and publicity is
good publicity as far as Russia is
concerned so that's that's really good
news but I suspect that so Jeremy's
lecture were
will arranged rather more widely than
current events in Ukraine I hope it does
because one of the biggest challenges
government faces today in its integrated
review if for gchq and the other
agencies indeed for wider Society
is how to confront the longer term
current but also longer term issues in
relation to the rise of China as a
strategic rival and competitor but also
one with whom we will continue to be
bound by wide and complex technological
and economic ties and of course whose
cooperation will be vital to tackle some
of the biggest Global issues of the day
so I'm really looking forward to hearing
what sir Jeremy says and as I indicated
Shashank will now explain the format for
the rest of our over to you
foreign
everyone thank you all very much for
joining us
um a few housekeeping rules before we uh
kick off please some fairly obvious ones
this event is obviously on camera and
it's on the record uh so
um uh just to remind you all of those
rules uh the questions you asked the
answers we hear are all on the record
um a few more specific rules for this
event uh please don't publish
photographs or media content of anyone
wearing a red lanyard for I think
reasons that will be staggeringly
obvious
um uh I think you can all see who they
are please please avoid that uh so
Jeremy is not wearing a red lanyard he's
he's he's fair game but please blackout
his face if you if you publish any
photos
um electronic devices please uh please
tell them to silent and I'll skip the
obligatory joke about gchq doing that
for you if you don't uh uh and uh more
prosaically in the event of an emergency
the science Gallery staff will direct
people to the relevant fire exits right
with that out of the way
um I'll hand over to Jeremy in just a
second I'll just make one very basic
introductory comment I think it's
interesting that uh in a period of the
biggest war in Europe for 30 years the
most consequential war in Europe for uh
uh 70 75 years that the heads of all
three agencies in the last several
months have chosen to make quite
substantial public interventions and all
of those have not really been about
Russia we saw Richard Moore talk in
Aspen Colorado at the Aspen uh uh
institute's conference about how China
was becoming his Services number one
priority uh remark he made last year as
well I was then at Tim's house a few
months ago when I heard Ken McCullum
alongside Christopher Ray the director
of the FBI talked about not Russian
intelligence in the threat post by
Russian intelligence to the UK and his
Partners but to devote that entire
intervention I think his first major
public UK intervention in that sort of
setting certainly alongside an FBI
director to the challenge posed by China
to UK intellectual property academic
freedom and a number of other issues and
now we have sir Jeremy who has already
talked I think in the past extensively
about China again here in this setting
uh delivering for us a lecture that is
about China I think that says something
quite profound about the trajectory of
British foreign policy uh the China
facing capabilities the way they have
evolved over the last several years I
think so Jeremy's the ideal person to
talk to us about that he took over a
general of gchq in 2017 and uh although
he may not be able to say this I think I
can in that five-year period the British
government has turned its public facing
approach to China drastic basically from
that we may remember in 2014 2015 uh
before his arrival to the situation now
where we have these uh Flagship public
statements uh warning of the threat from
China in very very Stark terms he
started his career his government career
at MI5 where he oversaw that Services uh
preparation for the London Olympics
um uh prepared work on the oversaw work
on the contest strategy on
counter-terrorism and at gchq he's
overseen a period of
um very significant flux not just in
terms of foreign policy priorities also
in terms of the establishment of the
national cyber security Center the ncsc
the defensive arm of gchq and also more
recently uh its role with the national
the establishment of the national cyber
force the ncf the um uh unit tasked with
offensive cyber activity which has
acquired more of a public profile in the
last couple of years and of course the
war in Ukraine has been a very very busy
time uh for for sir Jeremy and his
colleagues so uh with that please join
me in um welcoming sir Jeremy to the
stage
good afternoon
I'm sorry I'm not CDs it sounds like he
comes with better food
but thank you sashank and thank you
Malcolm uh for your kind introductions
and to rusi to inviting me to give this
year's annual security lecture
now you don't need to be direct to gchq
to recognize that we're living through
an incredibly difficult period
it's one where the threats we face as a
nation are changing rapidly probably at
the fastest of any time in my 30 years
in the intelligence world
it's one where we're constantly
rethinking what we mean when we say
National Security and what that means
for our work
and the result is that sadly I'm spoiled
for Choice when I think about where to
focus this lecture
the way in which different forms of
extremism are coming to the fore the
changes we've all felt living through
the pandemic the realization that
resilience is now a completely different
concept the rise of cyber crime
President Putin's unprovoked war in
Ukraine the role of non-state actors in
conflicts around the world the so-called
Gray Zone
and I could go on
but today I want to focus
on what I believe is the national
security issue that will Define our
future if you like it's the James Webb
Telescope view as opposed to the
binocular View
so I'm asking if China is the question
then what is the answer
now everyone in this room understands
that China has become once again a
strong Nation one that's investing in
its education developing its Industries
growing modern digital and Technical
capabilities building a capable military
in fact a nation that is evolving into a
superpower on its own terms
as it is for every nation technological
innovation is key to China's growth
and that's because it's so Central to
how we communicate how we trade how we
work and how we live
but it's also integral to intelligence
to military power to cyber operations to
health security to resilience and of
course to economic growth
and as such it's a provider of strategic
advantage to those able to harness its
potential
now China understands all that it's
deliberately and patiently set out to
gain strategic Advantage by shaping the
world's technology ecosystems
so we need to ask ourselves
are we happy with that
at this point I think it's important
that I'm clear that we have no issue
with the nation of China Rising up to
meet its potential
and we certainly have no issue with the
people of China and the Chinese
Community who contribute hugely to life
here in the UK
the UK wants to compete and to
collaborate with a strong China
but it's how that strength is used or
it's misused by the Chinese Communist
party that's at the heart of the issues
we face
so we must also be clear that when it
comes to technology the politically
motivated actions of the Chinese state
is an increasingly urgent problem that
we have to acknowledge and we have to
address
and that's because it's changing the
definition of national security into a
much broader concept
a technology has become not just an area
for opportunity for competition and for
collaboration it's become a battlefield
for control
for values and for influence
of course
first and foremost this is all about
science and engineering
But ultimately
it's about our way of life
and we in our like-minded allies see
technology
as a way to enable greater freedoms
greater Prosperity greater Global
collaboration and yes Fair competition
but the Chinese leadership's approach
is to also see it
as a tool to gain advantage through
control
of their markets
of those in their sphere of influence
and of course of their own citizens
and an increasingly complex and
interconnected world we see this as a
major risk to our future security and
prosperity
and without the collective action of
like-minded allies
the Divergent values of the Chinese
State We Believe will be exported
through technology without mindful
choices today we will Sleepwalk into a
future where technology limits our
tomorrow instead of helping to release
it
now you don't need the power of my
metaphorical telescope or gchq's covert
intelligence to see this happening or to
know that that's a problem
many of you will heard me speak about
cyberpower it was an attempt to provide
a framework to explain how in the Cyber
age nations gain geopolitical and
economic advantage
and we said this comes from their
defense of their digital homelands from
their ability to contest and compete in
cyberspace and from the shaping of the
digital rules of the road based on the
rule of law and Democratic Values
and all of these elements are
underpinned by the technology ecosystem
that I've just touched on
I think if you
've usually on Ukraine for a moment
you can see this framework in action
Ukraine's resistance to the illegal
Russian invasion
is a result of their National Unity but
that resistance also depends on their
access to a Mastery of advanced
technology
the alliances and trust that enable that
supply and of course impressive and
agile cyber security
now that's a government to government
thing
but it's reinforced by incredible and
deep support from the private sector
especially from the big technology
companies
now we're very proud of the role the UK
played in Ukraine's defense
that's over a decade of UK and Allied
investment in cyber Technologies and
Advanced Equipment together with a
willingness to share intelligence to
drive operations
it's enhancing Ukraine's Security in
real time
and it's redefining how cyber can be
responsibly used
so far from the inevitable Russian
military victory that their propaganda
machines spouted it's clear that
Ukraine's courageous action on the
battlefield and in cyberspace is turning
the tide
having failed in two major military
strategies already Putin's plan has hit
the courageous reality of Ukrainian
defense
with a little effective internal
challenge
Putin's decision making has proved
flawed yesterday's attacks in key even
across Ukraine are another example
it's a high stake strategy that is
leading to strategic errors in judgment
their games are being reversed
that the costs to Russia in people and
Equipment are staggering
and we know and Russian military
commanders know that their supplies
ammunition are running out
Russia's forces are exhausted the use of
prisoners as reinforcements and now the
mobilization of tens of thousands of
inexperienced conscripts speaks of a
really desperate situation
and the Russian people
started to understand all of that too
they're seeing just how badly Putin has
misjudged the situation
they're feeling the draft they're
fleeing the draft realizing they can no
longer travel they know their access to
Modern Technologies and external
inferences will be drastically
restricted and they're feeling the
extent of the Dreadful human cost
of his war of choice
now Wars are always partly decided by
the applications of Technology
and one of the most important legacies
of World War II was our that our
predecessors realized the power that
comes from staying ahead in the
technology race of embracing Global
markets Global r d and Global standards
the prosperity that followed fuels
collective security amazing new
technologies especially those that led
to leaps in global connectivity and
computer science underpid underpinned
incredible gains in living standards
I'd argue they also played a large part
in enhancing the great alliances of our
age
those that form the basis of what we
know as the rules-based order
and they show that technology security
economics and statecraft are entangled
and mutually dependent
now China benefited from all of these
developments too
their economic growth has been Stellar
since the country opened up in the 1970s
millions of people have lifted
themselves out of poverty
and that's been accompanied by equal
growth in its Science and Technology
China has led the way in patent filings
for the past decade in 2019
the country accounted for 43 of the
world's total patent applications 11 of
the UK's research output now includes
Chinese authors
now with that financial and scientific
muscle came in understanding from the
Chinese leadership that if all arms of
the state
could be harnessed to accelerate this
further it would help sustain these
incredible levels of growth
and it could be used to strengthen their
military reach
to coerce those with different World
Views and of course to maintain their
control at home
and we see that approach playing out in
the Chinese armed forces the large and
well-funded intelligence agencies and
increasingly in the way the Chinese
state is projecting its interests Beyond
its immediate borders
much of this is very public declared
strategies like the Bri the Belton Road
initiative and the SRI the scientific
relations initiatives
but much is also Undeclared
using debt leverage obfuscated
investments in critical Industries
old-fashioned spying
to steal intellectual property and Ghana
influence akem McCallum and Chris Ray
talked about this in their joint speech
earlier this year
and we're all seeing plenty of activity
from the Chinese intelligence agencies
now taking together overt and covert we
must conclude that Beijing is using all
of the levers it has the challenge the
international post-war consensus on
economics and Technology
and that it intends to rewrite the rules
of International Security both close to
home and further afields in ways frankly
that none of us have faced before
now there's an obvious Paradox at play
here the Chinese leadership believes it
draws its strength its Authority from
the closed one-party system
they seek to secure their advantage
through scale
and through control this means they see
opportunities to control the Chinese
people rather than looking for ways to
support and unleash the potential of
their citizens
they see Nations as either potential
adversaries or potential client states
to be threatened to bribed or coerced
now the parties bet their future on this
approach
shutting off the many alternative
futures for the Chinese people in the
process
they hope that future success based on
this system will be inevitable
but underlying that be belief and here's
the Paradox is a sense of fear
a fear of its own citizens a freedom of
speech free trade open tech tech
standards and alliances the whole open
Democratic order and the international
rules based system
it's therefore no surprise that while
the Chinese nation has worked to build
an advanced economy the party has used
its resources to implement Draconian
National Security laws a surveillance
culture and an increasing increasingly
aggressive military
and we're seeing that fear play out
through the manipulation of the tech
ecosystems which under underpin our
everyday lives
from monitoring its own citizens and
restricting free speech to influencing
Financial systems and new domains
now I think that's the wrong choice if
you're serious about investing and
building World leading science and
technology and I know it's the wrong
spot of choice if you're serious about
unleashing the potential of your people
now this plays out in the intelligence
world too many of you will remember the
debates we had in the UK almost a decade
ago around the intelligence agency's
license to operate
they're centered on the need for greater
transparency
and they led to the passing of new
legislation debates about the use of
bulk data stronger safeguards for
individual privacy deeper thinking about
ethics and we welcomed all of that
debate
in Beijing I believe that the leadership
took away very different lessons from
that time
I think they saw the potential of cyber
to seize an advantage over their
competitors or to clamp down on consent
they recognize they needed to bend
International flows of data around the
indo-pacific region towards interception
platforms inside China they sought to
steal data from deep within the critical
infrastructure of the countries across
the road across of countries across the
world especially those selling raw
materials to Beijing hosting allied
military bases or with Industries
competing with those owned by the party
Elite
and China of course there was no open
debate on this new Global surveillance
system indeed it's targets where it's
much its own citizens as other nations
they saw an opportunity to bolster the
great firewall to restrict free speech
and to throttle the growth of Western
Tech firms by slowing and blocking their
services
and today that surveillance system
appears ever more established
and we think it's dangerous
now much of this is also playing out
Beyond China's own borders
and in the way they're seeking to
subvert Global Security standards in a
bid for more control
to see what's at stake here you only
need to look at the new IP standards
that China put to the international
telecommunications Union the itu in 2018
now this appeared to come from Chinese
industry
at the hand of the Chinese state was
very clear
major Chinese tech companies are rarely
allowed to move in this space without
direction from the party
Now new IPS proponents portray it as a
revolutionary system that will prepare
the internet for the future
but we could see it would fundamentally
change some of the principles which
underpin the internet
and we think it would reduce
interoperability and therefore increase
the fragmentation of systems it would
cause a move away from the
multi-stakeholder model towards greater
government control
and tracking with all that implies for
human rights
now thankfully this proposal has not
taken root in the itu and the UK had a
role in this but it won't be the end of
the story we can see many other
proposals in many other standards bodies
so together with our allies we need to
remain alert to make sure that these
ideas don't take root elsewhere
now control is also a major driver for
Beijing as it seeks to build a
centralized digital currency yes it
introduces efficiencies and new ways of
settling payments but the way it's being
implemented allows the monitoring of
citizens and it forces companies to use
the service
it might in future also enable China to
partially evade the sorts of
international sanctions currently being
applied to Putin's regime in Russia
and be in doubt by the way the Chinese
Communist party is learning the lessons
from that conflict
and we're even seeing how that fear and
desire desire for control affects new
domains like space China's development
of the biodo satellite system a rival
alternative to the established GPS
network is moving quickly
is providing navigation to aircraft
submarines missiles and Commercial
Services and the party has used every
lever to force Chinese citizens and
businesses to adopt it
and for it to be built into Chinese
exports to more than 120 countries now
around the world
now on its own this might just feel like
sharp elbowed competition
but if we price in the motivations I've
been describing you can see it's part of
a concerted
strategy
and many also believe that China is
building a powerful anti-satellite
capability with a doctrine of denying
other nations access to space in the
event of a conflict
there are obvious fears that this
technology could be used to track
individuals too
so where does that leave us
the Chinese Communist party is right
that is the future of strength in the
21st century
but I don't agree
in the longer run control is no
substitute for the advantage that comes
from empowered citizens open societies
and standards secure alliances
nonetheless
that Paradox of great strength combined
with fear
is driving China into actions that could
represent a huge threat to us all
now I count myself lucky to live in a
free Democratic Society open for global
trade with truly collaborative Global
Partnerships
while the Communist Party in China see
weakness in how we choose to live
we know that this is in a fact the
source of our strength
and I believe that it's by leaning into
this difference that we can prosper and
find that answer to the question of
China
so what are our strengths that set us
apart well firstly we see the value in
collaboration We're a nation of
innovators we invest in science we host
World leading academic institutions we
encourage and value expertise and we're
not afraid to share any of this with the
world
secondly We're a rule-making nation
the UK has deep experience of setting
workable International Tech standards
informed by open democratic values
and we're at the heart of the
international and Allied efforts to make
them stick in a really harsh
geopolitical world
thirdly we've got a strong legislative
and policy framework which we use to
protect technology and markets
through the National Security and
investment act and other legislation
government has new powers to intervene
in transactions that pose risks to our
national security
but it's not all about protection we're
also investing heavily in emerging Tech
startups including through the National
Security Strategic investment fund to
gain the benefits
of innovation and make sure that they
don't fall for the promise or
alternative cheap capital
fourthly with responsible and Powerful
National institutions with the
capabilities and the experience to
actively take on the threats to
Nationals to our national interest
and that goes for our covert work too
wherever we at
including in new operational areas like
those undertaken by the national cyber
force we do so in accordance with
international law and our own domestic
legislation
it's an ethical proportionate and legal
approach that really does set us apart
from our adversaries
and lastly we have deep and enduring
International Partnerships based on
mutual interest and shared values
where we and other like-minded nations
collaborate to enable greater security
and prosperity authoritarian States use
each other only when it's in their own
interest to do so
so these strengths
give us a great Foundation
for action
and from where I said I think we need to
continue to make deep investments in the
next generation of key National Security
Technologies
for example we know our security and
prosperity will depend on mastering
Quantum capabilities systems which are
exponentially more powerful than our
current digital Technologies and that
push at the edge of known physics
these are on the horizon and they may be
closer than we think and our companies
universities and intelligence agencies
cannot afford to be to to be late to
that Quantum Revolution or be relaxed
about the extent to which others
especially perhaps those in China are
watching our progress
so we must continue deep engagement with
the global market whilst recognizing the
risks this brings
the manufacturer of advanced
semi-conductor chips is an obvious case
in point
they enable everything today from our
smartphones to the advanced weapons that
are being used to defend Ukraine
and Taiwan of course is patiently
invested in their semiconductor
manufacturer and it now supplies the
world and in the UK we cannot recreate
the scale of their manufacturing
capabilities so as a result events in
the Taiwan Straits any risk to that
vital supply chain have the potential to
directly impact the resilience of the UK
and Global future growth
and that's just one example of why the
UK tilted its National Security and
defense efforts towards the indo-pacific
in the 2021 integrated review to be
resilient at home we have to be
resilient globally
and that of course means working very
closely with our allies
now some Nations don't know which way to
face
and for them we must continue to offer a
credible alternative
so that they can retain their several
sovereignty in technology and their
National Security
and many are looking on with concern at
China's actions around the world
for example in the Solomon Islands they
see huge Chinese loans paying for
Chinese technology upgrades they see
countries
reaching deals with serious strings
attached
this may be the offer of new
technologies like smart cities which
have the potential to export
surveillance and data or there might be
demands for new bilateral security
treaties
mortgaging the future by buying into the
Chinese vision for technology may be
attractive to some in the short term
particularly for those Nations suffering
the stress of high energy and food costs
which have resulted from the Russia's
invasion of Ukraine so we need to offer
alternative solutions that are practical
that are affordable and that are back
are backed by International funding or
Market investment
and if we don't in the longer term the
hidden costs of China's cheap Technology
Solutions will become very obvious
now in a future crisis Beijing could
exploit information covertly extracted
from client economies and governments or
use its monopolies to demand compliance
in international forum and to catch a
glimpse of that future one only needs to
look at how China has already sought to
do this leveraging its influence over
many smaller nations in votes over
technology ethics and foreign policy
so if China is the question and Science
and Technology is part of the answer
what should we do next
our task as a community is to understand
the challenge
to know that Chinese Tech domination is
not inevitable
to take action
so I Ask of all of you is to think
beyond beyond the illusion of the
inevitable to lean into the strengths we
have as a nation to develop ethical
approaches and collaborative
Partnerships and to recognize that
creating an alternative competitive and
compelling offer for technology is an
opportunity for the whole of society
that we can't afford to miss
across the UK we need businesses and
Academia to be alive to the threat I've
described today and to make the choices
make choices accordingly
and while governments can set the
conditions this isn't about a single
grand plan
I think this is going to play out in
your boardrooms
in your labs in your team meetings
evening even
you should be protecting your systems
and your intellectual property you
should actively manage the Potential
Threat in your dealings with China
the seemingly small daily choices around
cyber investment IP protection and more
they all really matter
now across the world our allies are
clear-eyed about the threat and together
both at the nation-state level and with
the private sector I know that we can
offer credible alternatives
this isn't a call to exclude or
marginalize China even if we could
it's a call for China to recognize that
it's to its advantage to play
responsibly inside the global system
if it does so it can help to co-create
the rules of tomorrow
but if it chooses not to to play a
disruptive role in International
Security technology and markets then
that will come at a cost too
now these are all massive geopolitical
issues and choices and I think their
resolution will Define our age
my organization will do all it can to
contribute within its remit
actually to bring together interested
parties
and we can see three particular strands
of work firstly understanding the risks
and threats posed by beijing's Tech
policies now what are the Partnerships
architectures and Norms that we need to
enable the open Democratic National
Security community
secondly enhancing the collective offer
from industry to protect and shape
Technologies generate compelling
Alternatives and enable the next
generation of international standards
and finally investing more heavily in
the Technologies where we must maintain
an advantage
if we're serious about seizing the big
opportunities for security and growth
now at gchq it's our privilege and duty
to help the nation navigate the sliding
door moments of history
this feels like one of those times
our future strategic Tech Advantage
rests on what we do as a community next
I'm confident that together we can tilt
that in our Collective favor
thank you
okay
thank you very much sir Jeremy I'm going
to ask
um a couple of questions we'll have a
short conversation here uh we're a
little bit over time we have about 20
minutes left so I'll I'll be very brief
then I'll throw it open to the floor but
also uh try and involve our virtual
audience who are listening to this as
well
um just to start with a lot of your
remarks were diagnostic you were
analyzing the problems setting it out uh
and you have some suggestions on the
necessary response and you called for
the need for alternative Solutions so
you said they have to be practical they
have to be affordable they'll be backed
by International funding or Market
investment my question is a fairly
simple one which is have we ever done
that are there any examples of us ever
having been successful in that effort or
is this you know Terra Nova as we as we
compete with the Chinese
I can see where we've done aspects of it
so if you if you look at some of the
support that the UK has provided to the
rollout of fiber in Africa Cloud
technology in Africa and some of the
analytical and Telecommunications
capabilities that go on top of that
that's been a major effort it's been
very well funded by the by the UK um uh
our government
but I think the issue is uh not on the
Technologies we already have on the
table in front of us it's those that we
see coming down the track towards us my
my proposition is that if we're serious
about our prosperity and our security
then we need to take a very long range
view the UK has great Tech and
scientific strengths we we count
ourselves as a great science power and
so when we look to where those strengths
are whether that's bioscience or it's
Quantum or or aspects of other aspects
of computer science then those are the
Technologies we need to double down on
and those are the Technologies we need
to put a wrap around
um if I was to go into artificial
intelligence in a little bit more detail
you know we are World leading in a lot
of the capability around that now we're
World leading in the research which is
um allowing the capabilities to use less
data for protect privacy more to develop
um a meaning meaningful
um offer for the future we're World
leading in some of the applications
around
um lower power use on chips for example
which will enable the running of those
AI
algorithms I could I could go on so I
think I think whilst we we can point to
some areas where we've done it
successfully the call is to Rally
against a future vision of where we
should be I want to just add one more
point which is to reflect on the
countries you've talked about looking
both ways or perhaps those that are
ambivalent there are countries that are
in China's orbit there are those that
potentially could be in its orbit and
there are those that are friendly with
us but don't share our
perspective on all of these things down
to the letter I'm thinking countries
like India here which have their own
very distinctive views on privacy data
localization uh the balance between
individual liberties and state power
which differs in many ways from those
you'd find in Western Europe I'm
interested not just in where the common
ground is but what compromises an
adjustments and accommodations we may
have to make because dealing with your
indias in Mexico's and Indonesia's may
be different to dealing with the five
eyes and our NATO Partners what what
impact does that have on your work
there's there's net if if you are let's
let's talk about the internet so if you
were to
um uh run that question over over the
internet then you would you would say
that there has never been a single
version of the internet but what the
what the internet has had is a shared
view of its underpinning standards and
and that has been developed over many
decades now with with widespread
um International agreement and input
from both private mostly from the
private sector and Academia actually and
in some cases from uh from governments
um irrespective of whether you're a
country that aligns with the UK and our
allies you have benefited uh from from
that standardization and from the
ability to to trade with certainty
trusting the technology that I'm getting
into now
um if if you uh irrespective of whether
you you agree with the UK stance if you
are content to uh to look to a future
where the standards underpinning that's
what of Technology are not ones that you
can assure they are not ones that you
are able to um understand the
underpinning Technologies and you have
serious doubts about aspects of uh maybe
all or some of the values that you know
have um have been in the context within
which they're produced then I think
that's a worse situation for you so I
don't I don't think anyone is calling
here for a ubiquitous
um uh approach to all of these issues we
need of course for Innovation for
prosperity and to reflect our regional
context to be able to extend some
difference but some things need to be
standardized and some things I think
need to withstand that sort of broader
scrutiny from a technical and from a
values perspective okay lovely thank you
very much um if you could please raise
your hands if you have a question I will
try and bring in people from across but
also from the virtual audience
um uh over there please gentlemen in the
Blazer foreign
and if you could please State your uh
name affiliation because we may know who
you are but the virtual audience may not
so we'd appreciate that Dominic Connor
I'd vote for the register
um I'm interested in why the Russian the
threatened Russian attack cyber attacks
that we were promised if anything bad
happened how basically been at the
leather student pranks
um what what does that tell us about you
know estimating the capabilities of
other countries and is is there worse to
come
I'm wondering which aspect most
vehemently to disagree with in that
question
um so Russia is an incredibly capable
cyber actor and has shown it is so over
over many years
um uh most recently of of course allies
have called out uh Russian and uh
Chinese activities over the last 12
months that have gone into
exploited uh malware with a global
impact and have the ability to collect
in intelligence and the the impact of
that I think has been very obvious to to
everyone so they are extremely um
capable I think that the question is to
what extent have we seen cyber in the
context of this conflict and and the
answer for that is we've seen a lot of
cyber in this uh conflict we just
haven't seen the film version of it you
know the the Cyber Armageddon the the
big red button that switched off
everything all at once and and the
reality is that of course that's not how
these things play out and so we we saw
um cyber activity from Russia in the
weeks running up to their their illegal
Invasion we saw cyber activity
which um had actually had quite a broad
uh impact including on the periphery of
Ukraine uh against ViaSat immediately
after their invasions and and if you
were sat in uh Keith at the moment and
you were responsible for uh that that
government cyber security you you would
be thinking that Russia is paying very
close attention to your government and
your system so so I think there's um
there's been a lot a lot of cyber I
think academically
um uh we're learning a lot of lessons
about how cyber fits with other domains
in a conflict-like situation and of
course we're not the only ones learning
that lesson I alluded to it
um in the speech and so when we're when
we're thinking about what China might be
learning from uh from Ukraine then how
to Brigade cyber capabilities alongside
all the other aspects of a conflict I
think is probably an area of a very ripe
research I I've no doubt rusi will be
thinking hard about this too I'd like to
channel a question from our audience uh
from our virtual audience uh
mysteriously named BP who hasn't
specified his name but uh perhaps works
for the Chinese Embassy what impact does
uh I think it's really interesting
because your speak was about sort of
Advanced Technologies and we think of
these in sort of startup and in the
intellectual side of it the question is
what impact does resource and raw
material control impact the future of
the semiconductor Industries including
Quantum Computing what can be done to
reduce constriction of these and I think
that's interesting because we we perhaps
the material you know hard tangible side
of this is is seems less important than
the intellectual property well it's it's
extremely interesting and of course what
it what it says is that technology never
sits on its own if I if a gchq as an
agency is often thought of as a
technology agency the truth is it's a
it's a it's a people agency and
brilliant people working with technology
with Partners within a context to make a
difference to our national security to
keep us safe and of course when you're
thinking about that broader Tech
ecosystem then the the the the the the
the the the
the physical attack is an important part
of it but but you've also got around
that a question of skills do we have the
skills that are sufficient to make the
most of that technology for the next
generation and you've got questions
around the resilience of the supply for
the manufacture of those capabilities
and they're very widespread debate about
the availability of rare earth materials
and certain other underpinning materials
none of that is particularly new as it
happens but I don't think it's been very
widely understood and certainly we
haven't gone far enough in in making
sure that we completely understand the
implications of alternative sources of
Supply
strangely enough I think it is one of
the positive outcomes from the pandemic
that nations are all thinking
differently about resilience and that
includes all sorts of Supply chains I'd
put that in that in in that camp too
thank you um I had a question over there
and also if it's okay Deborah Haynes
over there but next to you I can spot uh
Sir John's College I wonder if it's okay
uh to to pick on you after Deborah to
get your view because it'd be very very
useful to have a human intelligence
perspective on some of these themes hope
you don't mind me by picking on you
afterwards as well
um thank you as Russia runs down it's
stockpiles of Conventional Weapons and
with Vladimir Putin showing no sign of
backing down in your opinion does the
risk of Russia resorting to a nuclear
strike increase and has tchq seen any
tangible evidence of that being prepared
beyond the rhetoric and if I may
um you talk about Russia running out of
weapons is there a risk of the UK and
European allies in particular running
out of weapons to support Ukraine first
I think there are three three questions
in there aren't there
um
so I said in this speech that that
Russia is running low on its
conventional Munitions and that its
commanders know that is the the case and
I completely
um stand by by that
and the question is I think whether what
we're
um
seeing
uh because of that situation indeed what
we've seen in the last day or so with
the with the uh the the strikes once
again across Kiev and uh the rest of
Ukraine whether that is escalatory in
its own right and I think there's a
there's a deep question around all of
that and I have to say it's a very
concerning time for for everyone as we
think about not least of course the the
ukrainians who are suffering the
Dreadful grunt of that um aggression my
view is what we saw yesterday
um was uh was an escalation in terms of
a return to that sort of targeted strike
much of it against critical National
infrastructure but it but it wasn't an
escalation in terms of the types of
weapons that are being used or the
extent to which those weapons are
bounded with inside inside that um that
conflict so in that way it continues to
follow the the uh the the the the the
shape the framework that we've had of
the conflict so far now Russia is the
only nation of course talking about
using nuclear weapons and I have to say
that's extremely dangerous to do so and
uh we we have have gone on record I'm on
record and uh and many friendly nations
are already on record and saying that
to to even be talking about the use of
possible use of tactical nuclear weapons
is is a very dangerous thing to do and
if if it is if there really is
contemplation about their use then you
know that would be catastrophic and
there would be
um serious repercussions from uh from
that
um I think your third question is would
we spot it and uh I I would like to
think that with our allies uh we would
have a good chance at spotting it but of
course there are never any guarantees in
uh in this space my view is for the
moment that Russian Russian Doctrine and
president putum's approach to this war
would see that being uh you know
hopefully a long way off uh but I think
we all need to be concerned about the
restaurant
so John
right well thank you for the opportunity
I didn't put my hand up
uh if I could uh you say from a human
intelligence point of view uh I am wary
of drawing too much of a distinction
between human intelligence and other
forms of intelligence it's all mixed up
you know you inform each other and
certainly uh intelligent communities
does do that
um so you know that's not you know put
down too many dividing lines
um I think certainly when I'm looking at
it and I'm thinking maybe with a human
intelligence background
um and the questions I'm asking myself
of the first one really is I need
absolutely to be clear in the Ukraine
context this is of what Russian
objectives are and that of course is
you're getting into the mind of uh the
other side if you like which is the
classic definition uh maybe of uh
intelligence tasking and if you can be
clear about that and there's a quite a
white consensus that he did is
effectively Take Over Control of Ukraine
and in the immediate term or in the
longer term but that objective remains
there then of course you can follow
through on um on you know what we can
expect to happen in the period
immediately ahead in the period long
ahead and I think we are all saying
really um and I'm agreeing that this is
going to go on for quite some time and
there's a very heavy commitment there on
uh the Russian side and they are
prepared to take very strong action to
back up their objectives so that means a
lot including a course in terms of
Destruction and casualties and uh and uh
and so on
um secondly we've touched on we've also
touched on the the nuclear point there I
would I would very much support uh
chairman saying
um there just is worth noting would you
know Putin is talking about you know
nuclear threats where he's talking about
it but it's always worth watching the
language that he's using in his public
statements and they do he has so far
unless somebody corrects me avoided uh a
direct connection you know a specific
threat if you invade this particular
Obelisk then you know I'm going to drop
a tactical nuclear weapon on you he
hasn't said that so it's up there in the
in the atmosphere as a concept and
there's an idea
um but it hasn't actually come down to a
completely specific threat on a
particular Target area and of course
there's a fine distinction but it's just
worth making making that point we need
to be careful because we're talking an
awful lot about escalation and
escalation seems to mean nuclear but of
course it can be a lot of things too and
we have to remember that and indeed
we're seeing that today and give for
example thirdly I'd mention uh cyber
because that came out of the questions
um and um I don't think I'm well I'm not
saying anything here I shouldn't say
because Lindy Cameron has already said
it uh that uh the uh skill and and
commitment and expertise which is there
in the defenses and the resilience which
the Ukrainian authorities have developed
over quite a few years now in terms of
cyber defense has proved to be effective
I mean obviously not completely
effective but it's certainly been
relatively um effective and that's a
lesson to be drawn and it's quite right
and she said that that really well
developed defense resilience and then
International Partnerships of course and
support which has come to Ukraine from
from the outside right so there's the
three you know some particular points
that um that I flag up thanks very much
um I want to Channel A couple of
questions from here because there are a
few that touch on a similar theme of
Chinese investment in the UK and uh our
universities and us and students
um so for example someone has asked
about over 114 000 Chinese students
studying in the UK you were quite clear
that you know you've been clear in the
past that your issue is not with Chinese
people Chinese community and Chinese
students but in the US we have seen a
real concern in the National Security
Community about the impact that such
high student numbers may have uh on
security concerns we've also had a
question about uh UK universities
collaborating with Chinese entities
including insensitive areas are these
things is a mood changing in in
Whitehall on some of these issues is
your approach this different to how it
was a year or a couple of years ago I
think the mood has changed over the last
couple of years and uh many arms of of
the UK government including
my own National cyber security Center
including the center of protection of
critical infrastructure cpni in in MI5
and uh and and others have provided
advice to Academia on how to how to
navigate some of these uh tricky issues
my my personal view is that we should
continue to welcome students from China
we could we should continue to seek the
benefits from that sort of collaboration
but we should be really clear about
where we want that to be the case and we
should be really clear on the areas of
Technology where we would require
additional safeguards if that was going
to work properly and we should be really
clear with the Chinese State about why
that's the case and then I I'm I'm after
a much more grown-up conversation about
what it is we really want to protect
what needs to be suffering what we're
happy to work with our allies and where
frankly we are willing to uh collaborate
now the The Sweet Spot here is is uh is
ongoing strong economic and academic
scientific collaboration with China but
but on terms that we both agree and and
it's not in that place at the moment are
there any priority areas that you would
warn universities about
um as terms of not being in that sweet
spot not having that balance are there
any areas of a particular concern I've
listed some of the Technologies where I
think we have a a genuine World lead at
the moment and and some of those are
areas we want to collaborate on and some
aren't but it's it's very it will come
down to aspects of Technology areas
rather than whole technology areas it'll
come down to the way in which our allies
perceive some some of those Technologies
I happen to think that for key aspects
of quantum and artificial intelligence
we have to be quite precise and more
precise in the argument
thank you very much we've run out of
time so I apologize to all those in the
thought that I couldn't get to it's been
a really thoughtful lecture it's really
interesting remarks very interesting q a
session I think what's become very clear
is
um the the trend I described at the
beginning and the focus on China the
focus and the integrated review on China
facing capabilities this isn't going
away uh you're doubling down on this we
have a refresh of the integrated review
coming up very shortly it'll be very
interesting to see what that says on
these issues but it certainly sounds
from what you've said like it's going to
preserve that a strong focus on science
technology uh it's not going to shy away
from China questions just because of the
war in Europe and we look forward to
your next intervention on these remarks
so thank you very much and please join
me again in thanking sir Jeremy Fleming